fun
[Musique]
on
notre courrier nous a appris que vous
intéresser beaucoup aux animaux et plus
particulièrement à ceux du parc
zoologique de vincennes nous avons donc
aujourd'hui installé nos caméras au zoo
et monsieur x sera le docteur bullier
sow directeur du parc zoologique de
vincennes qui va répondre aux questions
que vous avez posé la première question
docteur elle est une question qui vient
de colette du chemin avant tout une
question générale
combien le parc zoologique de vincennes
compte deux pensionnaires et bien ici
nous avons beaucoup de pensionnaires
nous avons des mammifères et des oiseaux
nous quand on a à peu près dans la
collection 650 mammifères et à peu près
autant d'oiseaux les gros zozos de base
tels que flamands aux perroquets
échassiers pélican marabout wii sont de
gros animaux autruches également oiseau
coureur nandous
aimez vous voyez que ce sont des animaux
encombre robert et muriel bas de
pontoise voudrais savoir eux c'est déjà
une question particulière combien pèse
un éléphant et quel est son appétit et
son menu quotidien
eh bien vous dire aux jeunes que rose
pendant deux sets extrêmement variables
le jeune éléphant lorsqu'il vient de
n'être pèse 90 à 100 kg à sa naissance
un éléphant adultes
un gros éléphant et micheline par
exemple mich desj c'est la réserve peut
peser environ trois tonnes
michine que tout paris connaît bien le
pèse environ 3 tonnes les gros éléphant
les gros éléphant d'asie les gros
éléphant de cirque les groman en
particulier peuvent arriver à peser cape
town 4 tonnes et demie dans la nature il
est rare de trouver des animaux pesant
pas pareil je crois que les africains
sont toujours beaucoup plus pesant que
les asiatiques
revenons à micheline quel est son
appétit et quel est son menu quotidien
micheline est un animal auquel il faut
donner énormément de fourrage un
éléphant d'afrique ou même d'asie de
trois tonnes doit manger par jour 50 kg
de fourrage à peu près 20 à 25 kg de
betteraves 5 kg d'avoine et sans compter
les dons généreux des visiteurs qui
malheureusement sont excessifs là nous
avons un public extrêmement généreux et
nous sommes obligés quelquefois le
lendemain les jours de fêtes de limiter
l'appétit de micheline pour éviter les
accidents gastro intestinaux jacqueline
et pierrot boutard à paris sont très
très curieux et voudrait savoir quels
sont les animaux les plus rares que vous
recevez au zoo de vincennes et bien
parmi les animaux les plus rares du zoo
de vincennes
je puis vous présenter ici l'okapi
l'okapi est un gir affidés un girafe
idées en provenance du congo belge et
nous avons eu le bonheur grâce à nos
amis belges d'avoir eu le don d'avoir
reçu le don d'un couple d'okapi le
premier animal le mal est arrivé en 1948
la femelle est arrivé un peu plus tard
et nous avons eu la chance d'avoir
l'année dernière la naissance d'une
jeune femelle okapi que vous voyez là
derrière moi à l'heure actuelle c'est la
première fois qu'un parc zoologique en
registre en captivité se noue climat
tempéré une pareille naissance il y a eu
des naissances de capi au congo belge
bien entendu dans l'endroit en captivité
dans l'îlot forestier dans lequel il vit
mais enfin il est tout même est
extrêmement intéressant de savoir que
c'est au zoo de vincennes au muséum
national d'histoire naturelle qu'a eu
lieu la première naissance d'okapi en
captivité et le besoin de vastes et il
reçoit combien d heures vincennes reçoit
chaque année
environ deux millions de visiteurs ne ça
aussi le chiffre 6 d'entre eux me dont
850 milles et près de 2 millions
parents enfants et bien nous avons à peu
près un demi tarif pour quatre entrées
alors voyez vous que nous avons
énormément d'enfants
ce sont les parents qui amènent les ans
et quelquefois le contraire c'est
justement ce sont des parents qui
bénéficient de l'instruction que nous
pouvons donner par l'examen de nos
collections vivantes
il y a aussi les étudiants les étudiants
et alors les enfants des écoles viennent
énormément les enfants des écoles
viennent en visite accompagnée avec
leurs maîtres les mercredis les jeudis
enfin les jours via des activités de
plein air des activités dirigées et
c'est un voyage c'est presque un voyage
autour du monde que de visiter le zoo
puisque nous avons nous pouvons évoquer
les pays les plus divers par les
collections qui viennent de tous les
pays du monde
jean pierre régner jacques finné denis
et marianne guérineau de paris
s'intéressent eux aux décors extérieurs
au zoo et dans ce décor ils ont remarqué
bien sûr le célèbre rocher et il creuse
quelle est sa hauteur de mon outil mais
bien entendu le rocher le grand rocher
du zoo de vincennes et creux il a été
fait d'abord et beaucoup de gens
l'ignorent il a été réalisé pour
maquiller pour camoufler un grand
réservoir d'eau qui se trouve à 40
mètres de hauteur un grand réservoir
d'eau qui sert à l'alimentation générale
en eau de tous les âges de toutes les
installations du parc zoologique
installations sanitaires au
d'abreuvement pour les animaux de l'eau
pour les bassins et en plus dans le
grand rocher dans le dans la pointe
supérieure qui mesure 70 m de hauteur
nous avons
escalier double et un ascenseur qui
permet au visiteur lorsqu'il fait beau
de monter tout là haut sur cette plate
forme supérieure pour admirer le paysage
où l on voit aux environs de bari à peu
près 30 lieux à la ronde
une question qui nous vient de lille par
la plume de christian poirier qui
voudrait savoir si ils s'échappent des
animaux du zoo de vincennes ce très rare
en réalité il y a quelques fois des
oiseaux qui s'échappe des oiseaux qui ne
sont pas et jointes et des oiseaux et
qui arrive à passer au travers des
grillages ou bien lors des perroquets
qui cassent leurs chaînes et ses
perroquets ne sont pas et jointes et
voici ce qui se passe le perroquet g
dans un arbre et pour le rattraper il
est une chose extrêmement simple c'est
de laisser sur le perchoir d'à côté un
ti camarades de captivité et dans la
nuit lorsqu'il a faim le père qui
redescend sur son perchoir
on n'a jamais rencontré de lyon du côté
de la porte dorée non les lions je
m'empresse de dire à vos jeunes amis que
les lions sont sous clé ainsi que les
ours et tous les animaux absolument
dangereux puisque nous parlions des
animaux dangereux
voyons un peu leur nourriture par
exemple combien de tonnes de viande est
il nécessaire d'apporter au zoo de
vincennes pour les fauves par jour
eh bien il nous faut beaucoup de viande
effectivement le problème de la viande
est un problème tragique quelquefois
chez nous nous nous approvisionnons war
nous avons des viande impropre à la
consommation humaine
nous trions ces viandes et nous les
donnons à nos animaux sauvages il nous
faut à peu près une demi tonne de viande
par jour pro fait rire la collection du
zoo de vincennes
et comme nous approvisionnons également
comme nous nous servons également pour
l'aménager gens les plantes
il faut à peu près 850 kg pour toutes
les collections vivantes du musée de
cire naturelle
d'ailleurs je m'empresse de vous dire
qu'il n'ya pas que les fauves qui
mangent de la viande qui a les oiseaux
les autres rapaces certains échassiers
et certains autres animaux qui mangent
beaucoup de viande
cette question a été posée par gérard
lelong à courbevoie et yves bloch à
marseille qui voudraient savoir
également si les gardiens peuvent entrer
eux mêmes dans la cage pour apporter la
nourriture défaut nous interdisons de
façon absolue au gardien de se mélanger
avec les animaux sauvages c'est une
règle absolue ici lorsque nous avons les
interventions à faire sur les animaux
sauvages c'est nous mêmes qui ont les
premiers dans la cage par conséquent
lorsque l'on veut entrer dans une cage
il faut au préalable un spécial animal
ou faire une pré anesthésie par exemple
la note de gardena où devait ronald et
lorsque l'animal était moitié anesthésié
et bien et sait nous vétérinaire de la
maison et qui sommes habilités à
pénétrer dans ses cages proféré une
anesthésie générale à l'aide d'une
piqûre par exemple pirette favre est
certainement une très petite fille et la
[ __ ] bougival et nous pose une question
que je vais vous lire littéralement
après tout ce que mange de bonbons de
cacahuètes de pain les sages est il
encore nécessaire de leur donner à
manger le soir a hélas vous touchez là
une question qui est tragique pour nous
nos animaux
que la conservation des animaux sauvages
est une quête un problème alimentaire
uniquement
mais si les visiteurs se substituer à
nous pour ce problème
tout est mis en question bien entendu ne
pourront pas étudié de régime
alimentaire pour nos animaux
nous sommes obligés de mettre nos
animaux à la diète la veille des jours
de fêtes ou à la demi diète et
malheureusement les lendemains des jours
de fêtes nous avons des accidents aussi
nous demandons à nos visiteurs de ne pas
donner à manger aux animaux
si chacun évidemment on veut montrer
veut témoigner sa sympathie à l'animal
en lui envoyant morceaux de biscuits et
bien le dimanche les animaux ont quinze
mille morceaux de biscuits les mêmes
micheline qui est un animal extrêmement
gourmand et qui a tout même de la
capacité qui peut arriver à manger 150
kg de pain par dimanche même micheline
le lundi est malade et nous avons eu des
accidents gastro intestinaux sur des
cervidés nous avons les animaux qui
meurent
nous avons des autruches qui mangent des
corps étrangers des cailloux des
briquets des des cigarettes des
trousseaux de clés fait les choses les
plus invraisemblables et nous sommes
obligés c'est aux jeunes justement que
je m'adresse nous sommes obligés de
demander à nos jeunes visiteurs d'éviter
justement de donner à manger aux animaux
pour ne pas faire ne vous connais pas de
réelle mauvais exemple précisément nous
parler les autres chez gisèle et alain
servat de puteaux nous demande si on
donne vraiment des montres à manger aux
autruches
alors vous me voyez lever les bras au
ciel évidemment les autruches sont des
animaux extrêmement vorace sont des
animaux qui mangent n'importe quoi qui
vous attrape les boutons et du veston
qui mange qui picole
les bagues des dames évidemment c'est
extrêmement dangereux de donner à manger
aux autruches de temps en temps nous
avons les autruches qui avale des
briquets qui a avalé tous aux clés comme
je vous l'aï dit tout à l'heure
et un jour nous avons eu une autruche
qui a mangé une boîte de maquereaux vide
n'est pas de maquereaux au vin blanc
absolument vide
et bien ce corps étranger l'a fait
mourir alors devant des accidents comme
ça nous allons être obligés de demander
d'une façon pressante à nos visiteurs de
ne pas donner à manger aux animaux
ils ne sont peut-être obligé un jour d'
interdire de donner à manger à tous nos
animaux ce qui est absolument lamentable
il faut que les que le public puisse
arriver à se discipliner et surtout
c'est aux jeunes que je m'adresse pour
cela rené thibaut habite pierrefitte et
il a des préoccupations très sérieuse il
voudrait savoir docteur quelles sont les
recherches particulières qui sont menées
dans les différents laboratoires du zoo
de vincennes en général
il est rare de trouver un jardin
zoologique comme le nôtre qui soit
équipé avec des laboratoires
nous avons des laboratoires qui servent
à personne des scientifiques pour faire
des recherches sur les maladies des
animaux sauvages
en effet lorsqu'un animal sauvage
meurent ici nous faisons une autopsie
il y a deux cas qui peuvent se présenter
premièrement l'animal meurt d'une
maladie contagieuse transmissible à
l'homme
immédiatement l'animal et détruits sur
place dans un four crématoire
si l'animal n'est pas mort d'une maladie
contagieuse transmissible à l'homme il
peut être mort d'une maladie contagieuse
transmissibles à l'un de ses congénères
alors nous faisons des prélèvements
bactériologiques des ensemencements et
en 24 heures ou 48 heures nous sommes
ainsi armé pour faire un vaccin et
lutter contre la maladie qui menace
l'effectif lorsque ces animaux sont
morts ils cessent de nous appartenir
il appartient en propre à 2 laboratoire
du muséum national naturel le premier
laboratoire et le laboratoire d'anatomie
comparée l'inventaire d'anatomie
comparer qui a été illustré autrefois
par le professeur plus grands cuvier
c'était à l'heure actuelle professeur
milo qui dirige ce laboratoire
il y à un deuxième laboratoire qui se
partagent les dépouilles de nos animaux
c'est le laboratoire de mammalogie vous
l'ont fait les études ceux des études
très poussées sur les mammifères et leur
batteur d'ornithologie ou fait également
des études sur
la morphologie des mammifères et des
oiseaux et ces animaux là sont montés en
pot on peut prélever dépôt pour
compléter les collections naturalisé
cela les collectionna tu réalises et du
muséum
voyez le but de l'établissement
scientifique en quelque sorte le parc
zoologique de vincennes est le
prolongement des collections naturalisé
du muséum national d'histoire naturelle
le zoo de vincennes est un monde qu'il
convient de découvrir avec persévérance
nous pourrions écouter encore longtemps
le docteur bullier que nous remercions
et qu'il nous soit permis de vous donner
un conseil pour bien découvrir pour bien
apprécier le zoo de vincennes
il faut y venir et y revenir
[Musique]